fans of Ozark have watched Charlotte
bird grow from a bougie wah teenager
living her privileged life on the North
Shore of Chicago into a ruthless
extortion artist living in southern
Missouri maybe not the best fodder for a
college application but more or less
what it takes to stay alive in the bird
clan it's a fascinating journey made all
the more convincing by the young actress
charged with portraying this troubled
teen her name is Sophia huh blitz and
you may have seen her on screen before
the fresh-faced huh blitz was born on
June 1st 1999 in Richmond Virginia
according to a profile in the last
magazine she moved to New York City at
the age of 7 there her mother an art
director introduced her to the industry
at a young age Publix joins Jason
Bateman's southern crime drama when she
was only 17 years old playing bateman's
daughter while the role of Charlotte
Byrd may have been her big break
it certainly wasn't publicist first
rodeo publicist first turn in front of a
camera came in 2013 when she competed as
a contestant on 7 episodes of chef
Gordon Ramsay's MasterChef junior TV
series during this run hub let's
famously became frazzled and broke down
in tears after making a mistake in one
of her tasks the typically ill-tempered
Ramsay's showed his softer side telling
hub 'let's not to panic in offering
personal assistance to help her rebuild
her batter mommy's help you please
hey don't worry it's thought again shall
we the fourteen-year-old huh blitz did
her best but she was eliminated in that
same episode of MasterChef junior
she clearly caught someone's eye because
she moved on quickly to scripted
television you bet with me I know you
can fresh off her MasterChef appearance
huh blitz did a two-episode stint on
Louis CK's FX sitcom Louie playing
Danielle Hoffman in a flashback arc from
there she was cast on a single episode
of CK's Emmy nominated webseries Horace
and Pete and then shipped off to the
Ozarks the fictional Ozarks the show is
largely filmed in Georgia for her first
shot at a series regular role public's
now stars opposite another young talent
Emmy winning actress Julia Garner who
portrays Ruth Lang more Batemans
erstwhile protege and sometimes
surrogate daughter although she hasn't
yet enjoyed the same critical
recognition as Garner after her
captivating performance on ozark season
3 it's clear that Hub 'lets future in
the industry is bright
he's not the one airing proof of public
says Hollywood star continuing to rise
as what's next on her docket
what breaks the ice directed by Rebecca
s crease the former assistant of late
the Silence of the Lambs director
Jonathan Demi who's gone on to become a
filmmaker in her own right
what breaks the ice is built as a
coming-of-age thriller centered around a
pair of teenage girls whose unlikely
friendship faces the ultimate test
publics portrays Sammy
while Madeleine Klein who's appeared on
series like the originals and stranger
things plays Emily the pair intends to
have a summer to remember but it turns
dark when they become accidental
accomplices in a fatal crime s Crees
once said of what breaks the ice the
film remembers a teenage experience that
may never exist again one in which
absent of Technology connection was
intense pure and evanescent with the
possibility of reconnection so uncertain
ultimately the film explores the liminal
space of female adolescents where the
realization of lost innocence transforms
into the painful and beautiful
empowerment of growing up
from the sounds of it what breaks the
ice will be intense in a ton of
different ways good thing huh blitz has
plenty of experience on a project
exactly like that check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
Netflix original series are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]